to do a quick live stream on my birthday
anyway to celebrate it with you guys
i just say hi now that i'm back from
canada
just say hi and uh yeah
just have a chill time just
ah relaxing yes hello
welcome welcome welcome welcome welcome
three weeks in the past is that what it
says
i was this freaking broken uh
is that what it says i never like
youtube with it's it's live right away
kind of thing
whatever it's my birthday now it is june
28th when i'm doing this right now so it
is
my birthday so hello hi welcome to
my birthday yes um if you're just
joining remember
lixian made me a game for my birthday
which i'm gonna play immediately
in about five minutes as soon as
everybody gets in here but happy
birthday to me
it's my birthday my birthday birthday
the day of
my birth and it is my birthday happy
birthday to me
and me only and literally nobody else so
happy birthday to me
um i'm now 32 i am another year older
uh speeding my way into the grave trying
to
full full completion uh speed run of
life
um pretty cool stuff uh oddly enough you
know my birthdays have never been
too much of a like big event for me
like i've never really been too
concerned about celebrating hugely
um but today is a busy one uh today is a
surprisingly busy one
so i'm gonna be doing that um and also
before i get started on anything and i
promise this isn't a distractible promo
stream it is not that's not
what this is i'm going to be playing a
game that lixian made me
alexia made me a game made me one and
that's what i'm going to be playing
today
but i did want to mention an episode of
distractible came out today
that might be the funniest episode that
we
ever have or ever will record um and if
you guys know bob
like i know you guys understand what i'm
talking about when i say
when bob gets angry it can be the
funniest thing in the world and not to
discredit his anger
not to discredit it like the anger is
you know you know i don't like being
angry either as you guys have seen in
the past
um but if you ever listen to any episode
of distractible
like make it the one today it's called
bob's fridge
and let me tell you we recorded that and
i'm not lying
we were we changed up the entire episode
that we were going to record because of
what happened
literally an hour before we started
recording
to bob it is the saga
of bob getting a fridge delivered
and while that may not seem like the
funniest thing to you
you have to listen to this episode to
check out
just the insanity of how badly
a french delivery can go like absolutely
true story that happened moments prior
to recording
however there's links in the description
to that you can click on that and go
there
um and if you want to go listen to that
later that's fine that's not what this
stream is about this is not a
distractible promo stream
thank you guys for listening to it but
also it is my birthday
and it is my birthday wish that you
listen to that eventually but also i got
a game for my birthday that lexian made
me
so thank you all so much for being here
i'm gonna get it loaded up right now
um there was a message uh that he had
that he wanted me to read
um before before i got too in the way
about this
um this is a message from from lixian
it's very nice it's very nice hello mark
happy birthday buddy
i know i've said this plenty of times
but i want to say thank you and how
incredibly grateful i am for everything
you've done for me
you're such an incredible human being
and i feel honored to be able to work
alongside you
take this game not only as a gift but
also as a thank you
for your generosity your patience and
all the opportunities you have given me
over these past eight years
now this game is different don't expect
something that looks like the damien
game
but i'm almost certain that you will
like it there's one thing you need to be
aware of
this game has an ending it might sound
weird to read that but you'll understand
once you get into it
but keep that in mind also there is
another pdf that you should only read
after you have beaten the game i really
hope you enjoy the experience
sincerely lexi it's adorable
that's fantastic thank you so much
alexian for making this game uh if
you're just joining i haven't played it
yet but i am about to load it up
right now um i have not seen this before
it is probably not going to be like the
previous game that lixian made for me
about two years ago in relation to
damian it's so funny i think that
the video of that game me playing
through the game that lexian made about
damien
has more views than actually than damien
itself
which i don't know how to feel about
but i am very appreciative of lixie and
all that
uh he has done for me and all the time
that he's dedicated to
uh my channel and the things that i've
made
and i just hope that he knows that you
know the support goes both ways
i i truly believe in him and and what he
does
and the talent that he has oh the talent
that he has
um it's really incredible uh you know
he just announced that i think he
announces so i'm pretty sure it's okay
to say but he just announced that he's
going to be a dad soon
um and it's just incredible um like good
for him just to to go
to imagine that we've been working
together for about eight years now
um you know obviously closer in the past
few years but just like
he's a good one and i'm lucky to have
him
help me with videos and to be able to
work with him
you know not just him work for me but i
want to work with him on stuff
um into the future because just like
he's incredibly talented
and uh i can't wait to see what he makes
and um
i'm always grateful for the stuff that
you know he makes for
uh for me and the channel um and you
know i've said it before but you know
it's true my channel would not be in the
same place without him
uh it would be nowhere near so yeah
it's pretty incredible so i'm gonna load
this game up before i get too sappy here
and uh let me cut the music here
okay i don't know what type of game this
is going to be
let's see this game is meant to be
played in one sitting there is no save
system
all right
oh hey hi uh we're getting right into
this so this is the game that lixian
uh made for me let me make sure
everything is 100 before i get too into
this okay
everybody settled in everybody ready to
go i don't know how long is going to be
i don't think it's going to be too
too long but just um you know we'll get
the birthday punches yeah
all right here we go hey hey you wait
oh oh well hi
god i got it's always a tough getting
into the voiceover
hello there how's he seeing you here
[Music]
oh this don't worry about this
it doesn't even work see
nothing to worry about so hey you
wouldn't happen to be busy now would you
uh god
[Laughter]
follow me oh i can't wait
oh my goodness what is this what is this
nonsense
this this door i
must open it a friend needs my help
it's of the utmost importance that we
get through but don't worry
i'm going to show you how
okay whoa what is this what is this
have you ever wanted to touch my pink
stash
i god i hope you guys have never wanted
that but maybe you do i'm sorry i'm
gonna turn the music down
well now you can welcome to the wharf
sash clicker oh my god
oh my god it's a clicker game the rules
are simple
do you click the stash you get the sash
no sorry still quite loud
stop clicking buy some upgrades and
eventually we'll get enough resources to
open that door
good luck you know from my experience of
opening doors it's not usually the best
idea
oh my god look at that oh my goodness
i love it i love it i
love it i really love it
turn the music down even more oh my god
this is my dream
this is my dream now he did say that
there was
an ending to this game so i'm assuming
that i'm going to figure out what that
is
go to door what happens if i go to the
door
amount needed 1 billion
1 billion all right fine i don't like
the look of that door
i don't like the kind of butt hole in
the center of that i mean it's not about
hold lixian please your art
is not a butthole it's it's beautiful
it's very ominous looking
all right wait why is this one
oh per click that's right okay per click
okay let me get this
up because oh yeah now we're cooking
now we're cooking okay so this is going
to take no time at all
here we go there we go
let's see it reduces prices for oh
reduces prices oh
okay all right so yes it is my birthday
it is my birthday and we're about to
open
ah okay
i uh this is a game that literally made
and i knew that there would be no
game that lixie makes without it getting
creepy in some way there's uh
there was no way don't like this
oh
oh lexie what have you done what have
you done
what have you done what have you done
okay sure oh good
hey look
[Music]
oh okay
okay
all right good god you know lixian is
just too talented for his own good he
just made this
while also editing videos he just made
this
i can't i can't fathom that like i'd
like to think that i oh sorry it's
allowed again
i'd like to think that i have a good
work ethic but when it comes down to
like
some things is like i recognize that i
no one has a better work ethic
just like this he just constantly is
making things it's incredible
i'm always so impressed always
goodness gracious i need to get like an
auto clicker or something like that
yeah so i don't know where this is going
but like i i'm pretty sure that i can
assume that it's gonna be
more creepy shenanigans like i don't
even know what this i think this is a
tactical shovel but i have no idea what
that is down there
i don't know what the big orb is like if
i had to guess
just like an eyeball or something i
don't know
i don't know
uh
no no what i got gotta do is i gotta
bind click to scroll wheel right that's
that's the real tactic there
but i'm not gonna do that i'm gonna play
this authentically because i don't wanna
rush through it just in case there's
more
more creepy interstitial interstitials
like what just happened there
yeah oh my goodness oh man i'm my
finger's gonna hurt just clicking on
the upgrades itself
oh my goodness i mean i do i do
like auto clickers i think that they're
very fun
um but the best the best strategy is
like
obviously getting to getting it to the
point where your clicks
aren't mandatory all the time not that
that's ever going to happen with this
because
my goodness i need to get to a i need to
get to a billion so if you don't know if
you if you weren't here before
uh i need a billion mustaches 10 million
of these things
50k of the tactical shovels and then 2
000 of
whatever those are which i don't really
know what that is
i don't really know what that is at all
i have no idea
i just i love i love the fact that
lixian um
helps build of the lore the lore of my
channel
the well-controlled and very crafted
lore of my channel that is very
consistent and logical at all times
yeah use a different finger nah i mean i
do
i do the double click technique
technique
whatever yeah one of these days i'll
just do a non-stop live stream of cookie
clicker or something like that
i do love me a good clicker game like
don't get me wrong i
i do like that yeah oh you can't see
this oh i'm sorry i'm sorry
yeah i'm in the way of that let me uh
move this down a bit
sorry sorry my apologies yeah you can
see the number go
up very satisfying i know
yeah i got i got it i got it i got it
i got it i got it it's okay
yes it is my birthday i'm gonna be doing
plenty of birthday
celebration stuff i'm uh not too
concerned about growing older
uh that's never been a bother and always
in the past
you know other things have happened also
it is uh it's
it's bob and mandy's anniversary today
they they just so happened to got
married
on my birthday that's like the thing
about my birthdays look
so many other things happen on my
birthday just like today the funniest
episode of distractible that will ever
happen
pertaining to bob uh came out so i can
always i can always rest assured
that i i will come second place on my
birthday
what i'm playing right now is a game
that lexian made for me
um with definitely some creepy
undertones coming across there
yeah your birthday in two days oh happy
birthday happy hour
yeah everyone wish bob a happy
anniversary
yeah yeah thank you so much for all the
birthday wishes i know that there's tons
of people that have made fan art and
stuff like that
but i always meme it up on my birthday
like i never take it very seriously
maybe he assumed that i would actually
cheat
because like i need to get a billion of
these and a
billion is quite a lot of these i don't
know
if he expected me to play this on live
stream because i know the nature of like
clicker games is that they take a while
like it's a time investment
maybe he did assume that i would cheat
maybe he assumed that
maybe he assumed that hang on let me see
if i can i'm going to cheat
no one judge me no one judge me
uh no one judge me stop judging me
everybody
and i got to just no don't install an
update why does my mouse software need
an
update it's just ah okay hang on hold on
hold on
oh my goodness did you just unplug my
mouse
i swear if this
i also ate a key lime no no it's not
cheating it's uh
god i don't care what's in the new
version the mouse worked
fine all right here we go okay keys uh
let's see actions um macros
commands keys how do
wasn't there wasn't there a way to
god damn wasn't there a way to just like
what are there a way to just
all right let me try to create a new
macro uh
click um
uh toggle i guess what
what oh my goodness
oh god okay what no
i just want to cheat let me reassign a
button on my thing
where's a button i just want to change a
button on my mouse i want to make the
scroll wheel do something different what
are you doing
what are you doing i just want to change
that's a thing i can do
ah
okay here we go no wait no
wait no wait no no stop
there was a way they updated god this is
what they do they update the software
to something that's not what i know that
it worked before i was able to go in
there and i was just able to change
the scroll wheel to be a mouse click and
now it's not
you know it's not that it's not even
it's not even on the list it's not even
look at this look at this crap
look at this crap see look there's no
scroll down there's scroll
left and right but i can't change the
down like yeah i could
i could i think i could change no i
can't even change use default
what do you mean what do you mean what
do you mean what do you mean
what are you talking about what are you
talking about
all right i'm not going to cheat you
know i'm better than that i'm better
than that i'm better than that i'm
better than that i'm not going to cheat
i'm not going to cheat i'm not a cheater
i got strong
thingies if there's one thing everybody
knows about me is i got strong
thingies very strong
very strong thingies like exceptionally
strong
wait oh i could unlock
oh i could unlock it at any time
there we go okay ah
yes even i have my own cryptocurrency
now
start collecting them you never know
when they might get
really valuable okay
all right okay i'm getting coins
all right i didn't i i guess i should
have assumed that you could have done
that at literally any time
ah i see now i see
i i see now i see
i see okay
oh each wharf coin generates a mustache
every sec
oh i see
i see i'm so
stupid god i'm
dumb why would anyone make me a game i'm
an idiot
i'm so stupid
i'm so stupid what about the camera it's
fine
you see the numbers what do you want
there's no other place to put it you
just
what it's just it's just there you go is
that what you want to see
so we have one shoe oh movie care where
where am i going to move it
it's my birthday i'll put it wherever i
want put it right here
this is where it goes just shut up
shut up you don't know me he's not my
mom
oh buy worf coins
uh oh oh interesting
interesting oh fascinating
oh okay
interesting fascinating
fascinating interesting very interesting
very interesting yeah top right
i don't want to put it all right fine
you know what fine
there's no pleasing you guys there's no
pleasing you guys
there is that better i wish i could put
myself
under the mustache so it could just be
like i have a gigantic mustache under me
yeah top right okay all you people that
know exactly how to be a youtuber
okay who is a successful professional
youtuber and who's out there in the
audience
okay i am a professional
not a professional streamer i'll give it
that that that you know i'm definitely
not
that i would say very confidently i'm
not that
however you know what i mean
you know what i mean you know what i'm
talking about here
you know what i'm saying you guys
understand what i'm getting at right
center right
i never understood that like i know
there's a lot of streamers that do that
and i know it's pertaining to the game
that they play but they'll put their
camera like right here
but it's always bugged me about that
i've never i've never appreciated that i
know there's logical reasons behind it
but i don't do things for logical
reasons
i'm not a logical person i'm just very
feel based
i'm emotional
mm-hmm okay
get the ominous rumble really up there
all right okay
[Music]
can i go back i cannot go back okay
ah
yeah i'm not afraid of you i'm not
afraid of you
i'm not afraid of you at all
hi see now my face is in the wrong place
okay ah so i need a key for that
okay all right good good
good great actually fantastic the best
100 of the best
what is with this what is with these
what is with any of this
bright
that rumble's really tickling my ears
oh
okay
what is that what is that
what is that what is that you see that
off to the left what is that what is
that
i'm currently playing a game that lexian
made for me
[Music]
oh
i'm a man now i'm another year older and
that means i'm another year braver
okay cool great
i'm assuming i need coins to unlock the
keys
oh fancy that
oh i don't like i don't like that i
don't trust that no way
no way in hell that's a trap that's a
trap that is 100 a trap
that is a trap i'm moving my camera
can't play a horror game like this
oh got rid of my mouse never mind i'm
not moving my camera
i'm leaving it like that i choose this
who is you who are you
that's fine i'm coming after you
oh oh
leave
no one tells me what to do no one tells
me what to do
no one no one tells me what to do
you think you know me i don't care if
there's a trap
give give to me give
gibber alright oh no
oh no
don't like that
lexie and you're a devious man
you're devious you're devious
you're devious man
devious devious
all right fine
fine i'll go this way then because i
choose to go this way
hello it's two butts pooping back and
forth forever
ominous rumble the sounds are moving
back and forth forever
please no hi
hey
and there you have it everybody it's
i'm moving back you can't tell me what
to do i'm moving back you know what as a
professional youtuber i say that my
webcam goes down here
and that's just the end of it that's
just the end of it you know that's
that's just the end of it how about
right right here
no no here no here no here
vote now in the comments of where i
should be
oh turn that down yeah
yeah good okay anyway where was i uh
coins right oh look how many coins
i have oh oh that's amazing
oh that's so good i have so many
oh okay can i upgrade these at all
actually at this point i wonder if it's
like better to do with this
like i can buy a lot of oh i buy one
coin at a time oh i goofed that
maybe i goofed that i didn't goof it i
didn't goof it
i didn't goof it at all no no top right
no
hey who's the professional youtuber here
who's a who's the perfect you get here
this is what you get this is what you
get
you know what this is what you get
this is the webcam you get now you know
what there
that's the place i fit okay this is
where i fit everybody
it's the only place for me this is where
i go
this is my hole it was made for me
i have to go in my hole guys all right
guys welcome to
part 12 of the game that lixie had made
for me
guys this is
i love this
[Laughter]
so don't worry about it guys don't worry
about it it's all good
it's all perfect it's
i am the door maybe i've already guessed
just how this is all gonna end i am the
door
i've always known it to be true
oh god did i max out yeah i mixed up
that already what do i need for this
three
oh i can unlock this oh i'll let me read
nah it's fine you know what's better
than buying cryptocurrency
mining cryptocurrency well in this case
digging cryptocurrency
with the powerful the legendary tactical
shuffle i know someone who really likes
those
but i bet you'll give them more use
start digging those coins
all right i will i am
i am do that
i am do very much that draining my
coins so that i can buy more tactical
shovels okay where am i at progress wise
i know this screen oh no i'm blocking it
oh no
i'm blocking it
how am i gonna fix this how am i gonna
it's broken forever now it's
literally broken forever look i'm trying
to change the game of webcams and let's
plays i'm really
pushing the concept people are brave
enough to
to uh to ascend to the level of uh
of youtubing that i am currently at like
i'm just so far beyond
everyone else so i'm really changing up
the game
in every way in every way in every way
in every way
my move my camera to the middle what is
that gonna do for anybody
what is it
oh wait no no it's still oh no what have
i done what have i done oh god
come on wait it's still not perfect
oh god okay i'm here now guys i'm here
and i'm gonna flip myself over there we
go now that's that's better
this is the quad
this is exactly what we've always needed
in the let's play world we're really
pushing it you know every day i just get
up and i
change the game you know every day i'm
evolving the concept
no one can keep up with me because i
can't even keep up with myself
you know how it is to be just an
incredible success at all times that is
just
what i am and what i do can't stop it
can't change it
all right full screen yeah yeah yeah
yeah
all right the next evolution of let's
plays uh you get to hear it oh yeah
this is the sorry wait no sorry i
apologize hang on wait no i've got this
okay and wait wait wait wait wait
yep uh-huh
there you go this is the next evolution
i'll never have to worry about copyright
so you just get enough of the game so
that you know what's going on you know
you can see a little sliver of the
numbers up there popping out of my head
upside down you know you're absolutely
right
this truly is the next
oh god i'm sorry everybody i gotta let
me hang on i actually have to fix this
it's really bugging me it's it's really
bugging me
oh no wait wait something's happening
top tippy top something's happening this
is too big
there we go that's too small i don't
remember what the size is perfect
perfect okay hey look i'm back i guess
um
anyway i'll go back to that room that
had the big old face in it
no guys this is what it means to go even
further this is different wait
how this changed
this changed why did this change
oh wait no it didn't change i just
wasn't in the right place it's this way
first okay all right lexian
for those of you who don't know oh hi
hey what's up i saw
hmm oh shovel
shovel oh i've seen a pile of dirt
and anybody seen a pile of dirt about
yay high
pile of dirt everybody know about piles
of piles of dirt
piles of dirt anybody
you seen some dirt all right cool
all right i guess they're gone now
i know where there's more dirt but i
just want to see the room with the face
if that's changed at all
oh yeah and crank that up
the aluminum the ammonium
oh and it's blocked no no this is
fantastic
fantastic looks you made this for my
birthday as a nuts i see you up
yeah lexie just made this for my
birthday what are you doing down there
what are you doing down there lies
lies lies about what who's lying
oh there's more of you
i don't like that i don't like that
uh-huh well i need
uh-oh hey what's up pal hey how you
doing
hi hello i'll be on my way then
oh hi oh i knew it i knew i needed
six thanks pal oh
hi hello hi oh good
don't you do that no laughing at me
who the hell you smiley i'll slap
you into tuesday
which tomorrow which is tomorrow
tomorrow
i'll be out of here thank you very much
tastes like blood great good
okay time for my next key
cannot wait blue key
all right okay
hi i see you down there i see you down
there what are you doing
what are you doing you weirdo
oh thanks
[Music]
wow that was loud um
just gonna yank high
mm-hmm good great great good all good
stuff
all good is that a ladle little soup
ladle
i love ladles love ladles
all right i think i need seven coins for
the next one
huh okay can't do anything about that
all right
yeah for those of you who are joining
this is the game that lexian made
for me for my birthday
that's a good friend
oh i don't have why did i think i had
more than that
i'm very stupid that's why i thought
that
[Laughter]
okay fine okay fine
escape i am trying what do you think i'm
trying to do
what do you think i'm trying to do thank
you oh red key wait i didn't even notice
that
okay so i have the red key that good
what happened back here by the way
oh oh
whoa okay i guess i'll just be on my way
hey
a mark coin good
all right so i need one more coin
[Music]
for the purple key
well this is terrible
i detect some terribleness
[Music]
i detect terribleness detect
terribleness
all right oh good let me dig these up
oh yeah wow is that a black and white
spiral never seen one of those before oh
i can't dig up the graves okay
i could've sworn that's what you wanted
me to do but oh
it's pre-dug
pre-dug okay well i got that i'm out of
here
good job guys good job guys
a mustache a mustachio
yes thank you for all the birthday
wishes well
i'm just gonna be on my way
[Music]
oh
well that's great
that's good that's good stuff
[Music]
yes oh
look at that would you would you look at
that
oh
[Music]
well things look a little different now
hmm i'm detecting that things are kind
of a little bit
different interesting
so i have one of the purple
weird ball all the music is gone from
here
ah okay unlock oh yeah
oh you found it good
keep it up we're almost there
are we are are we are we almost there
are are we are we almost there
not not percent sure i guess
these are kind of slowed down a bit
and elixion deserves a hell of a raise
oh oh i can't buy that i thought the
sound just cut out for some reason
uh-huh yeah this is good um so what i'm
gonna do now is i'm gonna i'm gonna take
up this bottom square because
i feel like you guys have seen
everything there is to see in there and
it's the least amount of information so
let me just
occupy this space let me exist in this
in this moment in this in this world
here
okay good now you see yeah it's good
it's a good it's a good thing this is
where i'll be this is where the finale
oh i'm facing the wrong way
guys ah guys
oh wait no this way right this am i
looking at the screen
i am i am i am i am i am i am okay
now i've got it now i've got was i
facing the wrong way the whole goddamn
time
uh you
why didn't you tell me why didn't you
tell me
why didn't you tell me how could you let
me just
be oh i have over a billion mustaches i
have
way more than i need
i have way more than i need good god i
have so many
holy crap i have so many oh my god
okay guess i'll buy more of these
then good
god
oh well those are expensive now how many
did i need to that
10 million okay so i got a billion and i
got 10 million of those
and i got so many billions of these
well not enough of these i only need 2
000 of these to continue and open the
door
so i'm pretty close to opening that door
so pretty good i guess
wait how many shovels did i need 50k
okay 50k
shovels got it okay
so that's maxed out
this is getting there this needs some
more time
i guess i can keep clicking for whatever
good that's gonna do me
yeah yeah oh for those of you who don't
know once again this is the game that
lixian made for me for my birthday and i
feel like we're getting close to the
finale of it god he's just such a
talented dude he's just so talented like
man
can you believe that can you believe
that i cannot believe it
can't believe it can i refuse to believe
it it's not something that i'm gonna
even believe
cannot ah
crazy not so
dumb i'm gonna let that percolate for a
bit
yeah that's great also uh if you didn't
know my birthday wish is for you to
listen to today's episode of
distractible
just because um it is probably the
funniest episode
that we've ever made i gotta listen to
it again god i
i haven't laughed that hard in a long
time
because it's bob angry right i said this
at the beginning but it's just like bob
angry about a delivery that happened
just moments prior to starting the
recording it is
oh it's magical it is just that's just
magical it's it's stunning
it's incredible i love it yeah anyway
i'm gonna let this percolate is it
yep i am now 32 years old 32 glorious
years
oh man i've been doing youtube a while
too yeah i mean i i know i i was talking
about this before i'm not first
generation youtuber but now i'm at the
point where like i've been doing it for
god how long have i been doing it nine
years nine years now
nine years yeah i think i think
something like that
long time long time it's cool to see how
my contents fall but it's so cool like
i don't know how many of you guys have
seen the very first dwarf stash sketch
which like the fall of slender man um
like that was the first sketch that had
wor
stash in it like war stash is just such
an integral character to my entire
channel it's it's fascinating to see
oh i think i have enough wait don't i
have enough oh my god i do have enough
okay wait uh here we go i guess
let's open the door i suppose which is
not
if i know about the door and if you guys
have seen don't open the door
i don't think opening the door is the
best idea
i'm not 100 sure about that but i'm
going to open the door
i mean what do you guys think open the
door i'm pretty sure this is
the right idea unless there's some
secret that i've missed there might be
some secret that i've missed
all right i'm gonna open the door oh
oh
[Music]
oh finally
anyway
oh you said it wasn't a real gun
ow
[Music]
meanie huh
there you oh
not who i'm looking for anyway gotta go
goodbye
do you know that guy just ignore him
hey look
do you think that's it it sure is bud
hell of a year huh
hell of a year oh
this is a little homage memento mori
now where could he be as long as i don't
find her i should be fine
oh
oh there you are damian i've been
looking all over for you
oh i will is do you you haven't seen
sleeping around anywhere how you
she's sleeping oh good oh good great
all right well anyway i'm glad i found
you i i got a great new idea
and we're gonna make a tv show
[Laughter]
okay
oh good
i don't remember when i said those
things
oh say that jesus
oh my god great stuff great stuff
great stuff i love it love it love it
love it love it love it love it love all
of it love it
if you don't if you guys don't remember
markiplier tv it kind of existed in the
middle of
a date with markiplier and who killed
markiplier so it's not like it was
forgotten like
you know but uh the missing link
i legitimately don't remember saying i i
don't remember saying that i think it
was like as a joke or
something like that like ah look on that
tv show like i was trying to imagine
oh god that was fantastic all right well
that is
the game that lixian made for my
birthday you have a mission now you have
to go
to lixian and thank him for me because
that was incredible
uh he does streams on weekends a lot he
plays scary games but also
just like he's fantastic so go thank him
for me
thank you for all the birthday wishes
now my birthday wish my birthday wish in
addition to going thank
lixian uh if you look in the description
right now there are links to
distractible and no this isn't just a
complete distractible promo but
literally if you want to laugh at
what will be the funniest episode
destructible we've ever made there's a
link in the description click on that
listen to the episode called bob's
fridge i
just came out today and it is just
it is incredible it is it is the best
uh episode we will ever make or have
ever made uh so go check that out
thank you for all the birthday wishes
link is in the description there's tons
of them you can see them on all the
podcast
platforms um but just like that game was
great oh the pdf right right right guys
wait wait wait wait don't go anywhere
what are you doing what are you doing
what are you even doing
what are you even doing there's more
you thought that was it you thought that
was it you're so
wrong everybody tell them that they're
wrong but don't go anywhere
the ethan voice okay i'm reading this is
the message that
lexian made for me after the game was
complete
so he told me to wait until the game was
done
and i finished it before reading this
one okay
okay here we go everybody ready okay
all right i'm assuming you finished the
game right go to the next
page there is a secret
ending
man everyone who left early is going to
feel real dumb when they find out
they missed this there's a secret ending
go to the next page to find out more
to get the secret ending you need to be
on the third visit
to the spooky house i know you're a busy
man and i respect your time so below
there is a cheat to get you there
right away
oh
interesting
interesting okay
okay all right
okay
well well well looks like we're not
quite done
guys looks like we're not quite done
i suppose there uh there's a little more
to this than we previously suspected
guess we're not done here after all
all right
it's fine i i didn't read what the
secret was
what the secret was was not provided hey
you right
hi there happy new year here there's a
gun it's not real
what happens if i there's there i know
there was an option i
oh okay i'm gonna try to say yeah i'm
busy okay
anyway all right can't believe
i can't believe wilford just shot us
like that can't believe that
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay
so oh oh
oh damn it oh damn it no no no
no no no no no no no no no here we go
okay all right
we're back in it to win it so there's a
secret
that is available on this visit i
actually almost got to it
accidentally but now i'm going to get to
it
for realsies yeah
yeah i legitimately almost got to it
just because i i do like to click on
random things but i didn't click on that
i think i clicked on the rock but not
not where i was supposed to click um
because i suspected that there would be
a secret i suspected
i didn't know for sure but i suspected
it i suspected it
and i think i know where to go from this
hi hey guys hey what's up guys
how you doing all right
yeah yeah
oh wow and then we go back here and uh
oh no it's blocked oh hey
nice thanks guys oh oh
[Applause]
oh i don't have the i don't have the
cribber i'm supposed to have the cribber
right
oh wait am i even able to get the
cribber i said i needed to get
that in six coins
i don't know if i'm gonna be able to get
six ones again
but maybe i will i think i do that's
right i think i do
hello yes man everyone that left is
probably feeling real dumb right about
now
feeling real stupid
meanwhile me i'm big smart huge smart
actually
the biggest smart is
okay that's four
that's four
oh thank you for all the happy birthday
wishes i really appreciate that
thank you so much i uh i have
plans for stuff to do on my birthday
and i we'll get to it
i almost had it you know i did i almost
had it because i i
i went this way if you guys remember i
went this way and to look at the rock
and i was like here oh but if i'd go oh
oh i might have even dipped my toe in
this
oh oh oh oh
log one i have been trapped in here for
a while this is all his fault
the mustache man he seems nice on the
outside but he is a devil
i'm just another one of his victims
another one to add to the pile
i have no idea i was helping a murderer
he already killed so many people
some who tried to help but couldn't and
others who refused to help
they know that if mustache man leaves
they can leave oh wait is this in the
right order
ah i was able to find out what he wanted
but when i
realized what he had done i hid it from
him he was not happy about it
his gun may not work however his hands
do somehow
i did not end up the same way as the
others their bodies are buried
but their souls are on the wooden people
i'm different
i can use my human form if i can call
this thing human i can't even talk
but i keep turning into this giant worm
monster thing
i can't control it i can barely move
without turning at least i think i can
and i can write i don't understand why
though why am i different
was it because i touched it a new person
got in here today he doesn't know that
he must not help him
he must escape that's not what the
wooden people want though
they know that if mustache man leaves
they can leave he's trapped in here with
us
i can't let him escape who knows how
many people he could kill if he left
this place
i may not be able to leave but maybe i
can help this poor man escape
i'll guide him warn him provide him with
the necessary items to proceed
i know i can help him if he can
understand the signs he must understand
that there is a window of opportunity to
leave
and he must take it or he will be
another one for the pile
okay okay
interesting there's a window
of opportunity to escape
there's a window
to escape
there's a window of abdorn
bundedy ascalope
a window
of aborgan dungalo
to escupe and i must
do someone's not happy
someone's not happy of me taking
advantage of a window
of opportunity oh
right there was a red door back there
i was able to escape to get away from
that murderer
i'm glad there was someone in there that
was willing to help without him i would
still be stuck inside her horse
dead they're still in there suffering
even
after their deaths i hope one day they
can escape too
and i hope one day the mustache man pays
for what he has done
that's not so bad what's not to love
about that guy
he's great but murder he's never
murdered anybody
he's never murdered anybody
never name one name one name one
name one name one
that was great that was fantastic i love
that
look oh that's great thank you links
again
thank you so much that was fantastic you
can't name one you can't name that's
good you can't name one you can't name
one
ah it's great
anyway so thank you everybody so much
oh yeah he's literally killed all of you
i told you to name one nah you didn't
follow the rule
you didn't follow the rules now i told
you to name one
you lose anyway thank you all so much
for the happy birthdays
um remember go send elixi and all the
love in the world for this game
uh and uh just thank you guys so much
for being here with me
here another year as i grow another year
older and i create more and more crazy
stuff
can't wait to show you guys all the
stuff that i've been up to it's uh
that's good that that was awesome and i
enjoyed that greatly
uh and also remember in the link in the
description below there's a distractible
podcast for you to listen to with bob
wade and i just having a good time and
today's episode that just came out bob's
fridge listen to that
it's it's just it's so good it's so
goddamn good i don't i barely say two
words in it because
we just kind of like stepped aside and
let bob ramble this is me and wade
laughing the entire time as bob loses
his mind
over the impossibility of this fridge
delivery like
and he just off the cuff like just
completely
from the back of his mind just like
gushed his hatred of the situation
and anytime bob is angry god it's so
funny it's so
goddamn funny so link is in the
description thank you guys so much for
being with me here
on this channel uh means the world to me
and uh i've already eaten
cake amy made me key lime cheesecake and
i ate it for breakfast so very
nutritious don't tell alex
but also if you do it's my birthday and
i have an excuse so it's all good there
it's all good
you don't think you've ever seen bob
angry on a tangent oh my god it is a
treat
it is a goddamn treat so go listen to it
it is
fantastic all right i'm gonna get out of
here though i got a busy day ahead of me
thank you everybody so much
for being here with me uh another year
another year to do crazy stuff
i can't wait to yeah i can't just wait
uh i can't wait to keep creating stuff
that's my favorite
thing in the world i love making i love
being here uh amy got me some great
presents already
you know and uh yeah it's just that's
just fantastic
so thank you everybody links are in the
description go send lixie and lots of
love and i will
see you in the next video bye bye
bye guys bye have a good one take care
bye
bye bye bye